so
the story is this at the end of the
second world war
uh the americans began focusing on a new
enemy
that was communism in the soviet union
that led to the creation of the cia
the cia decided very early on
mistakenly that
communist powers and communist
scientists
had uncovered the key to
mind control they'd found a way to seize
control of human minds make people do
things out their secret commands
therefore the cia launched an intensive
program
to try to compete with this as i said
it wasn't really true that anybody had
ever found these secrets because they
don't exist
but the cia went off in this direction
and it began a program called mk ultra
a highly secret program that ran during
all of the 1950s
specifically aimed at trying to find
ways to control
the human mind
in 1951 the cia hired a chemist named
sydney gottlieb
a person who faded into total anonymity
and lived his whole life
completely invisible sydney godley
became the uh chief of the chemical
division
of the cia so he's the chief chemist of
the cia
um in this capacity he also became the
director of mkultra
first of all it's just amazing that the
cia has a chemistry department
well godly had his phd in chemistry
and i called my book poisoner in chief
because whenever the us government
decided it needed poisons
godly was the person who could make them
he knew more about poisons than anyone
in america
i think maybe more than anybody in the
world so when the united states for
example decided that we wanted to kill
fidel castro with poison
in 1960 it was godly
who made the pills and the poison
fountain pen and the poison wetsuit
when the united states decided we wanted
to kill the prime minister of the congo
patrice lumumba in 1960 it was godly who
made the poison kit and
brought it over to the congo uh but
actually
that wasn't the most important part of
sydney gottlieb's work
by compounding those poisons to kill
foreign leaders
he was essentially just a pharmacist he
was just a really smart chemist who knew
how to
extract minute amounts of toxin from
alaskan butter clams and compound them
into
super potent poisons but another
gifted chemist might have been able to
do that cotton leaves work
it was much more secret uh on mk ultra
was the real key what a bizarre life and
a bizarre project uh he was responsible
for
so godly set out
on his uh mission find the key to mind
control
by uh in a very scientific way
concluding that if you want to find a
way to
implant a new mind into someone's brain
you first have to find a way to destroy
the mind that's in there
so the focus of mk ultra became how do
you destroy a human mind
or human body or human spirit
uh godly asked himself who knows about
this that's another great
scientific step you would take like what
data is already out there on the project
i'm about to undertake
who knows about how to torment people
how to destroy their minds
how to poison people how much poison it
takes
and how much shock it takes to create
certain horrific impulses well
the only people that would really know
about this would be the doctors from the
nazi concentration camps
and their japanese counterparts so those
people were brought
into the cia and became part of mk ultra
sydney godley who was actually the son
of jewish refugees from europe
wound up working with these former nazi
doctors
in his project of trying to find ways to
destroy human beings
so uh how did he do this godly
was given the authority
to travel around the world to places
like germany and
japan and philippines and he could
requisition human subjects
from the cia station there or from
military police
these were called expendables they were
people who could be
tortured and killed and nobody would
notice either they were suspected enemy
agents or they might be refugees who had
no connections to anybody
and they would be brought to secret cia
prisons one of which i visited in
germany
and uh made subjects of these horrific
experiments
so how would those experiments go for
example
i found one where uh certain subjects
were strapped into sensory deprivation
chambers
and then fed with overdoses of
amphetamines so they would become
hyperactive within their restraints
then fed mega doses of
sedatives that would put them into a
coma and when they were in the
transition phase from hyperactivity to
comatose
they would be given heavy doses of
electroshock
to see if all this together might work
to destroy their minds
when i visited this one of the safe
houses that i think might have been the
first ever
cia secret prison in germany the uh
young german guy who now owns the
building
was very accommodating and he took me
down into the basement and he said to me
these storerooms are the cells
in which the cia doctors
along with their nazi counterparts
just continuations of the experiments
that the nazis had been conducting a few
years earlier in the concentration camps
just down the road
and the guy owns the house also said to
me
everybody in this neighborhood the older
people they know what happened here it's
not a secret it's been published in a
couple of german magazines as well
and they've told me he said that um
the bodies of the people who were
experimented to death
are buried in places that are now
covered up with shopping malls and
apartment blocks all around here so
godly had what amounted to a license to
kill issued by the u.s government and in
pursuit of his mk ultra mind control
project
he carried out the most intense and
extreme experiments on human beings that
have ever
been conducted by any agent or
authority of the us government
why what is the purpose of mind control
and why the hell would the cia want to
control people's minds
alan dulles the director of the cia had
concluded that
if you could make people in other
countries behave as you wanted them to
you wouldn't have to kill them uh
but i think the the deeper question is
what led them to believe that this was
possible
and i think there are two answers one of
them has to do has to do with a few
specific
uh episodes that happened there was the
story of this hungarian cardinal who was
placed on trial by the communists and
spoke in a very monotonous voice and
with glazed eyes and confessed to crimes
that he obviously hadn't committed
it later turned out he had been coerced
by the same means that
people have been coercing prisoners with
since forever but we didn't believe that
we
we thought that he had been mind
controlled somehow
the same thing happened with the release
of our prisoners from korea
a number of them that said good things
about communism and confessed to
committing war crimes
we thought the only way they could have
done this is if they had been
brainwashed
so somehow was those kind it was false
interpretation of events
but i think there was something even
bigger than that something that was
behind that
i think those seeds fell on fertile soil
and that fertile soil was
cultural conditioning think of all those
stories about mind control it's a
fantastic
trope for fantasists
you drop a pill into someone's drink i
mean how many books how many
movies and stories have come out of the
the
swinging clock watch that makes you
hypnotized
there's been edgar allan poe stories and
sherlock holmes stories and movies like
cabinet of dr caligari and gaslight
these guys in the early cia grew up in
this culture
and i think they confused the the line
between reality and fantasy they began
to think that what uh
screenwriters and novelists could
imagine just any scientists could make
real
and so that's what they hired sydney
gottlieb to do find out how to do this
in real life and the justification was
it's all defensive they're doing it we
need to do it to save ourselves and i do
believe this is one of the lessons of mk
ultra for today
so what led them to
feel that it was all right to go to
these extremes
i think it was their fear of
the threat that was out there we had
convinced ourselves
that soviet communism was endlessly and
ceaselessly plotting
our total destruction that that
apocalypse could happen
at any moment and that once the soviets
struck
not only would america be destroyed
but the entire possibility of fulfilling
life on earth would be over forever
with the stakes that high the loss of a
few lives or even a few hundred lives
would seem like a very small price to
pay
and the lesson i think is that you can
always work yourself into an exaggerated
threat mode where you think that
well we always as a nation abide by
ethics and morality
and laws but there have to come some
very extreme circumstances where
temporarily we have to leave that behind
but the temporarily never seems to end
and now we're again in a situation with
world terrorism and all the threats we
face where we're told
well civil liberties can't be respected
quite the way
we normally would like to because we're
facing an extreme threat
so commitment to a great
cause is the
most powerful motivation to commit
immoral acts
and there's no cause that's more
seductive than
patriotism i think this is what brought
people like sydney godley
and his bosses at the cia into the
mindset
that even the extremes of mk ultra would
be justified